Speaker 1: So I am, for better or for worse,
sort of continuing my mia culpa.
I have completely been underestimating the
relevance, power, importance and potential
of this kuhnen wing of the Republican Party.
I talked about this.
I think it was on Tuesday or Wednesday, this
week, I think Tuesday.
And every day I am learning more about the
reality that we probably should have paid
a little more attention to this to begin with.
There's a new vice article pointing out that
Kuhnen already has 19 candidates running for
Congress in 2020 to.
David Gilbert writes that as the GOP becomes
more receptive to the conspiracy theory, more
of the cult's followers are running for office
with 18 months to go before the twenty, twenty
two midterms, Kuhnen supporters are already
seizing on the GOP's embrace of the conspiracy
theory and growing their hats, throwing their
hats in the ring for a seat in Congress.
So far, 19 people who have publicly shown
support for the Kuhnen conspiracy theory have
declared their intention to run in House and
Senate races across the country, according
to a Media Matters investigation.
Recall our revelation.
I guess we would call it our discovery from
earlier this week that based on new polling,
one in five Americans on average.
Yes, more in some parts of the country than
others.
But one in five Americans on average believes
at least one of the three major.
Q And on conspiracy theories, the one about
the child pedophilia inspired by Satan, the
one about there may need to be a violent sort
of take down of the centers of power in order
to save humanity or the country or whatever.
And what's the third one?
Oh, the third one is.
Yeah.
Like the conspiracy of, you know, the elites
that are secretly controlling and manipulating
deep state type stuff.
Those are the kind of three major branches
of Kuhnen conspiracies, 20 percent of the
country believes at least one of those.
And we are seeing this reflected not only
in voters, but we are now seeing it reflected
in candidates.
Now, the logical fear would be.
If 20 percent of America believes at least
one of these conspiracy theories and you've
got what will probably by November of twenty
20 to be dozens of candidates who believe
the stuff running, the 20 percent that believe
in that stuff, we're going to go and vote
for the candidates and we're going to have
more kuhnen in the House of Representatives
rather than less.
I think that we would safely say right now
Marjorie Taylor Green is a kuhnen person.
In some sense.
Matt Gates is a kuhnen type.
I don't know what the full like is.
Madison Cothran Kuhnen is Lauren Bobert Kuhnen,
I don't know.
But when you see 19 people already running
with a year and a half to go, that's not good.
That's not good.
The article in goes on to say, All but one
of the candidates are running as Republicans.
The single anomaly or anomaly, both are acceptable
pronunciations.
Is Mindy Robinson running as an independent
in Nevada's 3rd Congressional District under
the Patriot Party of Nevada BANER.
Like 14 others on the list, Robinson was a
candidate for Congress in 2020, and like all
but two of those, she lost.
Oh, OK.
This says the two candidates who won that.
Her cue are Lauren Bobert and Marjorie Taylor
Green, both up for reelection.
The number of Kuhnen supporting candidates
is likely to increase as the twenty twenty
two election approaches in 2020.
The final tally of Kuhnen supporters who ran
was 97, according to Media Matters.
For America, like many of the candidates on
the list, Bobert and Green have sought to
distance themselves from the most extreme
fringes of the Kuhnen movement, despite repeatedly
displaying support for the conspiracy on social
media and in video interviews.
This is a real concern now.
I don't know that we could have done that
much more to stop this before now in the sense
that there was not really the sense that this
would be significant.
And so if you can't convince people that something
serious, how do you get them to activate against
it?
I don't know.
But now we know it's serious and now we know
that it's real.
And one of the things I'm most interested
in seeing in these upcoming Trump rallies,
Trump is restarting the MAGGA rallies and
he's getting the old 757 tuned up and getting
worked on so he can start flying into rallies.
One of the things I'm curious about, aside
obviously from seeing what Donald Trump sort
of emotional state is, the interviews with
the supporters at these rallies, it's not
an election year.
Twenty twenty one.
It's not even a midterm election year.
It's just a random it's a non big election
year.
What is the mindset and the tone and the mood
and the perspective of the people that go
to a June twenty, twenty one Trump rally?
And that, I think, will give us a sense of
how prevalent this movement is within the
people that are going out to support Trump.
There's a real question as to is the Q movement
more of a stay home and type stuff up on the
computer type group, or is it more of a go
out to the rallies type group?
I fear that it's the latter and that they
are going to really make their presence known
and felt strongly during the twenty twenty
two campaign.
And every indication now that this is far
more serious, far more serious than we imagined